because this this guy is supposed to be
some sort of big billionaire
and he's been running ads on on newsmax
and oan and all kinds of places
apparently
begging people for money like him it's
not like
a super pac asking people to give money
to make america great again or oh we
need to make sure that president trump
is reinstalled or some [ __ ]
it is him looking into a [ __ ] camera
saying please send me your money
anything will help a nickel a dime a 20
bill
please send it to me i'm [ __ ] broke
this is supposed to be a billionaire
you know the guy that stood up said i'm
super rich
i can afford my own campaign i don't
need no money i'm not beholden to no
money
and here he is here he is begging
for [ __ ] chump change it's crazy
all the griffs all the griffs that he
had while he was present and this
motherfucker's still out of money
is anyone wondering that maybe the
criminal grand jury
at the manhattan d.a in the state of new
york
that has his tax returns is anyone
wondering
maybe maybe just maybe that's why he hit
his tax returns all that time he doesn't
give a [ __ ]
about committing crime this guy thinks
he's above the law he always has
all his will he always thinks he's above
the law
god damn he's donald trump why not
his dad bailed him out all those years
the banks bailed him out
the government bailed him out with with
bankruptcy
and the republican party continued
continuing to continue to bail him out
during his presidency
he's always going to get billed out he's
not worried about crime or corruption
he's worried about people knowing he's
[ __ ] broke
a rich billionaire does not go on tv
and produce a commercial looking into a
camera
begging people to give him money
stop what happens so maybe
kevin's right maybe kevin's right the
bill came due
on the web page and he couldn't afford
the 995 this month
it is the second he couldn't afford the
995 this month to keep that [ __ ]
open